I'm talking to mr.
William brindle who was an assistant
photographer on the sydney harbour bridge
working for the public works. Do you
remember how you first got the job. Do most
mental. Well yes i was
a junior. Salesman in the shop
at kodak in george street
and i've been there for about two years
and i was very keen to get out into
photography and of course these were the
days when tough jobs were pretty tough.
And one day one of the senior men in
kodak said to me. That mr bob bowed and
whose aim with the public works
department was looking for
a junior. And that he would need to introduce
him to me or introduce me to him as
the case was and this happened and
eventually i got the job with bob
bouton and we were then located
and bridge street in the works
building up on the roof and these
were the days of course of glass plates.
Our standard plate in those days with what
we termed a whole plate which
was eight and a half by six and
a half inches in size.
And. The cameras were
a big beautifully made cameras of
cedar and brass and very heavy
and i was to find that out as the bridge
progress and they had to cut these things
up over the bridge arches and so on. But
before that time we were involved in
work this was before they actually the
bridge was started being built. We were
involved in work which required us to
photograph some of the old buildings around
the rocks areas and buildings that were
adjacent both on the north sydney side and
the doors point side to where the bridge
excavations would be made for the pylons.
And also the blowing up of the or gun
emplacements that dawes point they were.
These were pretty solid concrete and
placement and the buildings where it
gammoned by. People from
the works department
. And all cracks were registered. By
them and then we were sent along to
photograph them and course these
were done in case of any possible.
Legal battles later on for damages as
a result of the blasting we. I suppose
did hundreds and hundreds of pictures
of this nature at that time. Well then
of course there was the building of the
workshops on the enormous your side
where luna park now stands and we
went on from there with the covering
the excavation work for the pylons
and well sort of i grew
up as the bridge grew
i grew with it because i started with bob
bad and when i was eighteen and spent
some years with him and i have
very vivid memories in those
days with these big cameras when
we got to the stage of the arch.
. Progressing across the
harbour. That you had
a very do what yourself in the afternoons
in those days. The southerly buses used
to come up very regularly about four o'clock
of an afternoon. And if you're up on
top there and with these big cameras in the
southerly buster was due. You went for
your life but in those days of
course the observatory used to drop
a black ball. If sadly buster was due.
So we used to keep our eye on the
observatory because it was very involved
so of course any rain about you wouldn't
venture up there because it was too
slippery and there are no guardrails or
anything of that nature.
It was just often just
a. Piece of rope but a cross between
a couple of stanchions for
you to hang onto. The
water member. Do you remember
ever going up the creek
a crane for taking photographs. Yes yes
indeed. And also on several occasions that
we were dropped over in these wooden
cages. To photograph suspended over the
harbour to photograph and you nearing
details which would be required
this at times would be quite nerve
wracking but after you done it
a few times you got quite a blouse
a about it. Do you remember. Do you remember
of preparing for graphs of plans for
bradfield early on. Oh
yes indeed we. We had
standard negatives of the various designs
for the bridges which were put away very
carefully and many occasions would get
rushed demands from dr bradfield to make
extra print of these which he obviously
had to present to cabinet or of the
government of the day to make his point.
And we would stay back often late at
night to get the truth
for him. He was a man
a very demanding fellow he he knew what
he wanted and he wanted it always wanted
everything yesterday. Dude remember that
he used to do up plans or used to do up
plans for the press. Yes
but not not very often.
I don't know how brad feels relationships
where with the press of that day. My
memory is not very good about this. Certainly
he would supply them with pictures
that don't because we're in those days we
were generally day only source of this
type of material is an embargo that the
sydney mail always got his early stuff and
then that was usually copied in various
other papers. Yes. What that could be so
that's what you're discussing mostly the
engineering photographs our plans and so
on. That's right. Yes yes. Well of
course that would be so i don't think we
supplied the press generally with actual
engineering details as the bridge
progressed i think generally they were
allowed to take their own pictures. Yes
right. Do you remember while you were
working on the on the bridge. If.
The various other people. The working people
did you ever photograph them at work.
Well yes we did because but generally
are work was only concerned with the
engineering details and if the other
people were in these pictures. They were
coincidental because we were not really
tied up in the human side of the of
the of the bridge building it was not our
function. It was we weren't doing a p.r.
Exercise as such it was it was you know
straightforward engineering detail.
Bob bad and was
a magnificent photographer and
he believed in accuracy and
the fact he was dedicated to it and but
i don't think that he he would ever
worry so much about human
interest but that you recall
a an incident that also at the same time
we were covering the building of the
underground tunnels for the railway for
the city railway and i remember on
occasions this would involve big flashes.
Of the tunnels where you would use their
own or blowgun type of thing which allowed
you to fire exposure to different
fire flashes rather at different points
along the tunnels and sometimes if they
were men working there you would see men
turn their backs to us or something of
this nature involved bad and said he's
got a premier criminal record. It's
a common thing they turn their backs on
you. Isn't it when it is right. I mean
within like the flash. No no i think of
those days cause you know the jobs are hard
to get and and for that type of work. I
don't think they were terribly fussy where
they got their labours from but this did
happen quite frequently but if you talk
about human relationships. My experience
of the harbour bridge workers was always
that i've never worked which that youre
more honest hardworking crowd who were
dedicated to their job their relationships
with each other were to my mind.
Excellent. And i think that they knew that
they were battling against the elements
and against all the engineering problems
to get this thing across and i think it
gave them more or less
a common cause. Yes many people have told
me that i was one thing i was wanting to
ask you. Its relation to dr bradfield
it seems to me. Looking back at the
photographs that you took that there was
a little you know inordinate proportion
have bradfield in the foreground. Well yes
. I think he was
a publicity seeker. I think of
course of that period there were
rumours that. Things were not always happy
between some of doormen long's engineers
and bradfield in my lowly position of
course i didn't know the the rights of this
but you couldn't help but but grasp them
and it was actually taking place but. I
think that possibly it had to push himself
because pushing himself he was pushing
the bridge and quite honestly i
give him full credit for this. Is.
Looking back also. Can you remember what
the well the conditions of work for you as
a photographer were like
in those days. Well we had
we had reasonable facilities there was
a lot of money available for equipment
or anything of that nature. But our
relationships were dumb and long were
excellent because they realized that that
they had access to our pictures and they
wanted them taken and in fact often our
pictures help them and the job because
we had regular intervals we would take
pictures. With the camera erected on the
triangle like triangulation points which
were situated there i think there are three
of them for memory. To ignore sydney
and one on the doors point side and these
were where the surveyors erected their
theodolite to check on the progress of
the arch to make certain that they were
holding their line across the
harbour and you know we always
received excellent cooperation from all
the doormen long people. And it was
a very happy time it was
a hard time in the sense that the equipment
was very heavy encumber some compared
to modern photography. Do you ever going
down to the quarry. No i never went down
to the quarry. But as
a funny story about that you did this
interview recalls about two years ago wife
and i were touring around the south coast
and i was fishing awful wharf in the
earlier river and up. Picked up. I didn't
pick them up. I lost him but i obviously
hooked a decent sized fish which i
thought must have been some sort of
a decent jewfish. And he took me
down under some debris in the
river bed. And i lost. I had to cut my line
away i couldn't get him up and looking
around i suddenly realise that this was
the war where the concrete where the
granite blocks for the harbour bridge
pylons were loaded and that only just
a few yards away was the start of the
quarry in fact i started to look around
and in amongst a long.